what's inspiring to you
what's insightful to you about several
of the presidencies
throughout the recent decades is there
somebody that stands out to you that's
interesting
in in sort of in your study of how the
office has changed
well bill clinton is one of the most
fascinating figures why can't i
i apologize bill clinton just puts a
smile on my face every time somebody
mentions him at this point i don't know
why
he gets charisma i suppose well and he's
uh he's
he's a unique individual but but uh he
um
he fascinates me uh because he's a
figure of such
enormous talent and enormous appetite
and such little self-control uh and such
extremes uh and and i think it's not
just that he tells us something about
the presidency he tells us something
about our society uh you know american
society this is not new to our time
he's filled with the norman enormous
reservoirs of talent and creativity
and those have a bright and a dark side
and you see both with bill clinton in
some ways he's the mirror
of the best and worst of our society and
maybe that's really what presidents are
in the end right they're mirrors of our
world
that we get the government we deserve we
get the leaders we deserve
i wish we embraced that a little bit
more you know a lot of people criticize
you know donald trump for certain
human qualities that he has a lot of
people criticize
bill clinton for certain human qualities
i wish we would kind of embrace the
chaos of that
you know because he he does you're right
in some sense represent
i mean he doesn't represent the greatest
ideal of america but
the flawed aspect of human nature is
what he represents and that's the
beautiful thing about america the
diversity
of this land with the the mix of it the
the
the corruption of of within capitalism
the the beauty of capitalism the
innovation all those kinds of things the
people that
start from nothing and create everything
the elon musks of the world and the bill
gates and so on
but also the people bernie madoffs and
and
and all is the metoo movie that showed
the multitude of creeps that apparently
permeate the the entirety of our system
so i don't know there's something um
there is some sense in which we put our
president on a pedestal
which actually creates
a fake human being like we
the the standard we hold them to is
forcing the fake politicians to come to
power
versus the authentic one which is in
some sense the promise of donald trump
is uh a like it's a it's a definitive
statement of authenticity
it's like this the opposite of the fake
politician
it's whatever else you want to say about
him is there's
the the chaos that's unlike anything
else that
came before
you